with kids now officially on holiday
break the mount charleston area might be
a place you plan to take the family to
see the snow maybe do some sledding or
skiing today lee canyon ski resort
opened officially and madison kimbrough
joining us now live near kyle canyon
road to tell you what to expect if
you're planning a trip up the mountain
madison
yeah i would say plan to leave early as
there's plenty of snow but parking is
limited as you can see we're right here
on kyle canyon road and as for lee
canyon ski resort there is parking up
there but the earlier you get there the
better spot you will have to carry all
your gear
exciting time obviously so this is the
beginning of the season
everyone can come out maybe like shake
the cobwebs off on the bunny hill a
little bit tis the season for snow lee
canyon is officially open it will look a
lot different this year as last year
there were limitations in place but this
season everything is open from the ski
school to the restaurant to the gift
shop and they're also hiring we're
looking across the board so i mean there
are food and beverage positions open
there are ski instructor positions open
so you know definitely go to our website
leecanyonlv.com
you know check out our jobs page see if
there's something that fits the momentum
is high for this season as several
skiers and snowboarders were out tearing
up the slopes for many it was their
first time to lee canyon i'm definitely
happy to be out here with with friends
and family and everybody and just
everybody around
just better than being locked down
better than than not being able to come
out at all it feels amazing because i
feel like this is my second home got our
passes right away got in there was no
hold up all the staff is out here
there's actually a lot of staff that you
can see so a lot of helping hands if you
need them for the ski resort as long as
there is snow and cold conditions
operators hope to stay open through
march
and a reminder what you bring up to the
mountain make sure to bring back so
you're not leaving any trash reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now